you come across as a very free spirit
and love being around people how do you
keep boundaries in place because I'm
sure now more people really coming out
to you and feeling like they know you
how do you keep a piece of yourself
I don't know I think I have a really
strong personality so I'm not really
sure that I will lose too much sight of
myself in fact I think maybe I've gone
through all the challenges and
heartbreaks are many are enough that I'd
like come back to my core so I don't
really feel under any type of threat or
concern and I also think I will never
have a chip on my shoulder or any of the
people that like are in the movie I I
don't know how successful the movie will
or won't be or you know how many I'm a
broad of an audience will reach but I
definitely know that we're all really
down-to-earth and really appreciative of
anything that comes our way and other
people and you know what they've brought
to our lives so we may not have same
boundaries that other people have you
know we're just probably going to stick
with the free-spirited open armed
philosophy in life works for Roger
works for Ron
you